so there's a fellow named Jonah Peretti
who is somewhat famous as the founder of
BuzzFeed whose role in inventing
morality or pushing virality and
clickbait has an important role in our
present Jonah was a graduate student in
the early 2000s at MIT Media
Laboratories and he had this amusing a
situation where he ordered a pair of
Nike shoes from the custom Nike shoe
shop and then they said well what do you
want - you know you were able to put
whatever you want on it and he wrote
sweat shop because he wanted that and
Nike wrote him back and said well you
can't use sweat shop it's inappropriate
slang and he said that's not an
appropriate sleighing blah blah blah
it's a real word and so forth something
they just canceled disorder and he said
you know can you send me a photo of the
Vietnamese girl ten year old who's
making my shoes and so he did this
little exchange but what's interesting
is kind of amusing is he put this email
on a website and then it became shared
and then was shared and then shared and
shared and it was you know not the first
but an early version of what we now call
virality you know some piece of content
goes crazy and suddenly you know I
talked to him about it he said suddenly
I was on the media everywhere and they
were asking me about sweatshops was like
well I don't really know about
sweatshops but this thing happened and
it sort of fascinated him and he thought
well here's a new way of distributing
content it's not broadcasting where you
reach you know millions people at once
it's through sharing and through
virality and all of Peretti's career
from that point forward can kind of be
understood as an effort to recapture
that lightning in a bottle so he was one
of the cofounders of The Huffington Post
in the mid-2000s and Huffington Post you
know it had a website but was also
trying to create stuff that could be
shared and shared and shared and later
on he founded BuzzFeed the point of
BuzzFeed in some sense was the master
the art and science of virality the
master the shareable click and I think
in some ways while that's you know sort
of a fascinating project
that's necessarily one of the ones
that's been the the greatest for our
culture but in any way what he did it at
BuzzFeed was very systematically trying
to understand what kind of stuff will
inspire you first of all to click on it
and then next to share it with your
friends and he found out that for
example cats are very effective he found
out that there are these categories like
oh my god or embarrassing or hilarious
or gifts or whatever so that that was
BuzzFeed's entire model was to try to
distribute stuff horizontally so
speaking I think some of these ideas of
what we call clickbait are in other ways
as old of the hills I mean I was
rereading some of the penny press
headlines in the 1830s you know hundred
and more than a hundred years ago
almost two hundred years ago and you
know they're stories of suicide stories
of divorces you know crazy things with
headlines that get you immediately
interested so you know it's older than
clickbait it's it's about enticing
headlines and that's been going on for a
long time some of these appeals some of
the question of why these things are
appealing is a question that is more
about biology than culture I think you
know there is a natural reaction we have
to certain things death sex violence the
enormous monsters one of the things I
did looking at this book what
researching this book I spent a lot of
time looking at successful propaganda
posters and the kind of things that
activate almost involuntarily our
attention and there you know the same
thing there are great muscular heroes
terrifying monsters women in distress
enticing food items you know it gets
back to like what we are as creatures as
to what attracts us and why shouldn't it
be that way I mean in the wild I mean
I'm not a biologist but you can imagine
the utility of if you see something it
looks like food that's going to get your
attention
or if you see something that looks like
danger well you've got to react and so
these
you know modern-day clickbait things are
getting at very basic principles of our
neurobiology that are there for a reason
now they didn't used to be to try and
sell us stuff or get us to click on
things but they're certainly in our
biology for a reason